no problem
[Music]
well good evening and welcome members
officers on those members of the public
here at the meeting and those joining us
virtually
item one on the agenda
apologies for absence
yes we've got apologies from councilor
Pennington councilor Annie Brenton
councilor David Brenton Council NFL
counselor Newton councilor Hawkins and
Catherine Hepburn
thank you
item two is to consider the council
minutes of the 31st of August 23 which
are pages
on your agenda
I'll just run through them starting with
page five
six
seven
eight
nine
and
10 11
and 13.
a proportion from the chair with someone
around the second against the law all in
favor be sure
and against
and abstentions
teacher that's um 244
two extensions and then cancel the
rights such as the road should be
playing
okay thank you
okay answer the three on the agenda is
public contributions uh it does say on
your agenda Pat there are no public
contributions we've had one late
application which I've decided to allow
and Mr John Lewis if you'd like to come
forward sir and come forward you come
forward onto the microphone here so
everyone can hear you oh well we're on
YouTube
and you have your three minutes when you
start reading okay thank you very much
Jeff let me speak tonight I appreciate
the excuse before coming to last bonus
Council so I wasn't aware that had been
changing the way that we participate so
I hadn't submitted the sign up rate it's
good to see some familiar faces from the
day when I was an elected member of this
Council
um it's really good to be here again
thank you very much
um I just want to very quickly speak to
you all about residential parking
permits and one other connected issue
that happened when I recently contacted
the council about a permit
um we haven't recently moved to
Torrington I've inquired recently about
a residential parking permit only be
told that they work on Friday late to
Monday morning
um I must thank you all for standing up
on the Thursday evening during covert
and clapping that's those of us that
work with NHS
um however those about the working Chef
who work night shifts during those
wonderful time for encoded and still
work night shifts those permit hours on
Friday Sunday morning don't work when
I'm asleep on a Wednesday afternoon
going out on Wednesday night to show on
the same people's lives
um I spoke to the council about this and
was told that the only way I could do
that is to either buy a season permit or
a business permit both of which are over
300 pounds a year more expensive than
the residential permit I see that as a
punishment for those who are residents
who work non-traditional hours in what
your own management course an
old-fashioned and Antiquated system of
parking codes
um in the process of speaking to your
department and this is the second Point
um when I spoke to the the manager
concern and I'm not going to mention
because he did he did correct his ways
but um councilor James this is for you
as the leader who holds a portfolio for
customer service
um it was quite apparent that this
Council after all the years of work that
they made to kind of bring into line
with some of the small number of
overzealous officers that accounts we
used to have two obviously into making
the authority back into the hands of
detective members is slowly starting to
slide away the magic concern was quite
ruined aggressive and I asked him how
the conversation had gone quite politely
from flash to bang in just a few seconds
he apologized and he actually then
became quite Pleasant to speak to
um but he acknowledged his own behavior
and realized that he was being
unnecessarily aggressive and changed
that needs to stop
I didn't I wasn't aggressive I don't
take abuse in the back of my ambulance
from patients I don't give abuse to
members of your office of the council or
any other local Authority it's a
professional two-way street and I would
like it to be the same but the most
point of all really with an
understatement if I read the statement
of accounts correct and I'm going to
spend of eight hundred thousand pounds
if I read that correctly
we haven't understand we haven't
understood maybe we could look at the
wide and Resident permits are issued and
the pricing of any other option for
those of us that don't work the
additional 195 and work night shift same
in people's lives so that we can park in
the areas which we live
thank you very much thank you Mr Lewis
I'm sure the relevant officer will look
into that and make contact with you
item four Declarations of interest uh
members with interest and declare should
refer to the agenda item describe the
nature of their interests when the item
is being discussed
item five is agreement uh gender items
between part one and two and Arnold part
two items
item agenda item six consider
correspondence for other business share
I have none on YouTube executive
president
so moving on to item seven an update of
Torres City council's carbon environment
and biodiversity planned Pages 14 to 74
on your agenda
Donna
I'm not going to say your time starts
now so
good evening councilors um hopefully
this is a fairly simple one hopefully
your
online climate emergency declaration
that we have a Target to be Net Zero
Department by 2030 as an organization
and that we um also wish Devon and our
district be in line with the Net Zero
Target 2050 which she played government
has set and we have a carbon ban and we
review it annually normally the update
would have been published in June but
because we've had elections and new
committees and so on and we've not been
able to do that so and the paper is just
to say that I have updated
the plan
um in line with what officers asked for
it's gone to the Council of climate
change working group and had some
comments to make they have been taken on
board and the plan has been further
amended and so I'm really just asking
Council to agree that we can publish
this it's not um it's only published on
the internet we don't do it as a payment
is so and it's just you know coming out
understand
so you had your hand up first yeah
um a couple of a couple of small small
matters
um queries as much as anything page 29
of the pause talks about what porridge
has done and solar power on the original
buildings Etc and how much it's
generated
it'll be really useful if we could
actually know how much we use
how much we generate versus how much we
use we're aiming the net zero and that
doesn't actually throw up I can see that
doesn't give us that bigger
no it's in the full carbon equipment
report so that's identified there
could include it
we've had some problems just with the
accounting because during covid and EDF
energy wouldn't come out and validate
our solar panel figures so that
they're sort of right but we've not had
them quality assured for a while so
could I do that next year when I know
that the figures are going to be more
accurate my other questions I think it's
a very important piece of work and
Excellence has potential
to be a very important project for the
country but we're including it on page
that's something that's happening
yeah the planning question hasn't even
been put in yet as far as I'm aware
um the company are asking Britain taking
the weight and Forest being cited by a
national government
should we really be including a project
that may or may not happen
that was included specifically at
councilor Pennington's requests and and
he wanted it to go in the same section
as our discussion on the actual clean
Marathon Innovation Center in the
leveling up funds
just seems a bit odd to include
something that is an aspiration planning
project that hasn't actually happened
yet
oh thank you yeah the accident as well
was put in during our climate it's um
through consideration of the plan
um I have the first event sitting home
and putting in was the reference points
um it may or may not happen but it's
it was some things go in with the Kelsey
the Rave recording
um yeah I'd just like to commend this
plan to council
um
foundations and services and carpet
Organics and all properties and our fan
Sports and everything
um but I would like to watch houses to
go the next step we've got this basic
material to work on now we need to take
some of the assessment of our properties
which has been done by the Estates
manager and we need to as soon as
possible prioritize buildings
owned by porridge and to incorporate
energy saving measures uh part of the
mission Bishops this makes sense
economically as well as in terms of the
planet this is the next step we need to
put money towards us we need to look at
all impossible sources we need to treat
this because of that the Virgin City and
play our part and we need to look at our
Transport Systems and virtually
opportunities to go Electric
reduction
um
and I would like to recommend all of
those analysis loads
um
I believe
yeah sorry lay behind you and hold on
pencil dog yeah she has your hand but
actually quicker yeah
[Music]
um frankly I don't see how we can
include something that we aren't in
control of and actually it could be
counterproductive when it comes to us in
terms of planning and
um and we've been screwed as us having a
sway one way or another the right if
it's taken out of our hands that's a
different matter but it's all their name
and it's not ours we don't find it so
why is it in that
as I said that was included specifically
councilor Pennington asked that climate
change working group that that section
we added so
um I guess the council decided tonight
that they wanted to open out if that's
possible
yeah I guess obviously similar to the
the previous project in the report it
could be just reworded as opportunities
that could arise still very simply
adding a word or two
um uh I'll say the Celtic Sea project
which is referred to on the page earlier
in the reports
no thank you
um
if you were inclined to do that then I
would wait for it yeah okay
um I can offer an amendment
um
but if you use phrasing that it needs to
do it without being done yeah yeah well
I think if we go along words similar
that the YouTube has just used that
seems to be are you happy with that as
well I'm very happy because it could be
wrong but it will be yeah that's fine
you got your hand up
support please
[Music]
and he against
foreign
thank you thank you
okay moving on to item eight on your
agenda council tax uh care leavers
discount policy Pages 75 to 78
and I believe Stacy is already there
was that good one thanks Chad
um so just by way of um brief background
and Devon County
um have approached torridge and all the
other Devon authorities in relation to
providing assistance to care leavers and
to support them in their transition from
the um care system
and also to the bill what's called The
Importance parenting responsibility and
so Devon County are asking that
districts will leave care leavers from
their liability to pay council tax up
until the age of 25
so Kelly was a person who has spent time
living away from their family
um even living with a foster family or
in supportive living or under any
alternative Arrangement arranged with
their social worker
um generally they leave the care system
at the age of 18.
so when a child enters the care system
that the local Authority has a What's
called the corporate parenting
responsibility which is a collective
responsibility of the council and any
partner agencies effectively to provide
the best possible parenting for the
child and safe regard that child
so under Section 13 of the local
government Finance act District councils
do have a discretion to reduce council
tax liability that is payable by
individuals
um so at the moment we've been given
some data which is on the second page of
the report from Devon County
um they said that College District has
approximately 58 care levers within our
district but that's been checked by our
records and we currently have
approximately 12 living in the tourist
District area
um so we words we meant this policy for
example for the Bill of years 23 24
that reduction would cost storage a
little over 8 000 pounds and obviously
what we can't say is how much the cost
would be going forward to us because we
you know we don't know the numbers
um so what we're asking tonight is for
members to agree this in principle but
with a full policy to come forward to
full council with the full details
because there's still lots of different
details that are being discussed amongst
the county and with the other districts
and I know that our section 151 officers
and suburbs and Ben's managers are also
on separate meetings so that policy
hasn't been agreed yet but it has to be
a consistent policy across Devon so the
proposal tonight is for members in
principle to agree
um that we will provide the reduction
for care leavers with a full policy and
full detail to come forward at a later
date for approval or not as the case may
be
thank you Stacey well you can see on
page 77 you're a lead member
um councilor Simon Newton fully supports
Us in this initiative
so I'll propose
cancer
well I just yeah it was interested
reading this through this afternoon that
you could say if you don't support it
with a mean person you are
but it's not that at all I just thought
then you leave at 18 you care somebody
before that something move at 16 or 17.
and the County Council of the ones who
are responsible for the Aftercare of
children you'd say children with young
adults that we've been in care then they
give them a finance package when they
actually need that care so um these
Stacy said there'll be a full proper
policy I'll support in principles but
they're asking questions around it and I
think Tracy's alluded to those so when
we see before the policies and how it
effect but you imagine in our district
the number of 18 year olds now 19 year
olds 20 year olds who leave home there's
an assumption to get supported by the
parents but they don't get it opened so
you know you're setting up two different
things that person gets doesn't pay any
cash and taxes until the age of 25 but
that lady there that chance
bouncing tax because he lives on his
orders his own flatbed gets the 25
discount but he pays the rest so
you know I support in principle this but
again in the back of my mind the
counting down says pushing those to pick
up some of this costs I think for the
chain it's down here is eight times
incredibly on the 12. it wouldn't
implemented but it could be a lot more
improved
actually this is an in-principle
agreement you're looking for yeah
absolutely it's Invincible because of
some of the details the council levers
just raised needs to be be discussed
okay I'll proportion the chair then that
we uh
all in favor please show
um
thank you
so much anything on item nine is the
annual report on Treasury management
pages
79-85
and over recorded thank you chair so
there's three occasions in the financial
year when treasury management is brought
before the council when the policy is
set which year when we look at the
revised budgets and also an outcome
so this is the occasion I'm going to
fall back to Council on our compliance
with the 2223 treasury management policy
and the reason why principal council is
there all sorts of inherent risks
attached to the treasury management
which when all of a sudden done is the
is the management of cash so we'll see
our Surplus cash that within financial
institutions and into circumstances in
which we will borrow from financial
institutions
this is the occasion where we report
back on our compliance with policy so in
February 2022 a policy was taken to the
council that determines what our
treasury management policies would be
now this explains who we would invest
with and how much we would invest in and
where they would be domicile well I'm
happy to report that we've complied with
the policy for that year and the report
details the initial part of the report
details the compliance with that policy
and also provides some backgrounds into
the management of cash in a year
so you'll all be aware that there are
some large increases in interest rates
in the year and as a consequence we
achieved much much more in interest
which has been really helpful and it's
helped to generate that in the space and
it's also of course the fact that there
will be an impact in the current Shield
as well with interest rates increasing
further and cash balances being that
over 20 million pounds
the appendix also details the other key
point of this report is the detail are
combined with Prudential indicators
so the potential indicators indicate the
circumstances in which capital
investment decisions are made so it
determines the Prudence The
affordability and the sustainability of
those decisions and it often refers to
the circumstances in which we will
follow
um well I'm again pleased to report so
we we complied with policies last year
and one thing that we'll jump out is
that we were quite significantly under
those targets and that's if there's
built into the program for 22-23 was
borrowing or the new environment Center
which of course as you all know hasn't
taken place yet and so that's a key
reason why our actuals are significantly
less than what we've budgeted or what we
assumed we would be borrowing throughout
the year
so thank you chair those are the key
points I wanted to mention all right
thank you thank you Gordon
um Gordon didn't mention the environment
Center
um let's not know the environment Center
it is it has got a new title uh off the
plumbing ahead on the operations
operationals operational Services just
operation operations okay here you go so
yeah thank you very much for that Gordon
thank you
um
yeah yeah so the recommendations yes so
yeah we know the treasury management
report on pages sorry from 2223 and note
the actual Prudential indicator of the
22.93
um
I'll propose him as lead member for fire
I have had a meeting
um with Gordon
um some weeks back and went through this
and got a lot of detail please don't ask
me what that detail was now it is quite
complicated as you can imagine but um
needless to say I think we've got an
excellent section 15 on officer England
he explained it to me very very large
and I'll propose it from the chair
number second one answer James all in
favor please Sean
she remembers chair thank you thank you
I content on your agenda uh Street
naming and numbering policy Pages 86 to
108 on your back and
um so the council has a statutory role
as the street namely numbering Authority
for the district uh locally uh we worked
with a set of rules and regulations that
are set out and then locally approved
policy
um that the team the Estates team
administered that function for us and of
the operation of applying postal
addresses is run through our State
student uh the policy that we currently
have in place is now 15 years old and do
a refresh so the team have taken a look
and updated and suggested some updates
for you that have been summarized in the
report in front of you so I just gone
through a couple of them
um firstly to amend the language of the
policy to allow holiday lets to be
addressed apparently aren't
uh to impose new restrictions on
publicity announcing street names of the
thoughts being approved by Victoria
Secret Council that's the proposed
change and that comes as a result of
some recent problems that we've had in
trying to And to clarify the addressing
criteria relating to planning
permissions and that's clarified in the
beginning amended report uh to amend the
restrictions on use of names of deceased
persons to set out a defined time limit
or anticipating this before with cancer
twisting uh that would go from 100 years
down to 60 is the proposed online to
amend the procedures to ensure that
addresses will only be allocated once
construction has begun on the address
site and that's just a procedural thing
for the team it's much easier to to run
that way imposed time restrictions on
street name consultations and again it's
a procedural matter to make it uh
Slicker for our customers and for us
operations run as an organization to
introduce formal requirements for
digital site banks for developments of
five or more properties and that's about
adding things to the desert here again
it's a modernization of processes and so
culture the written procedures and
information to better reflect the actual
processes that's just about an
explanation so as I've set out or as
it's been set out in the reports in
front of you this is all about
modernizing we've done consultation
Street naming officers participating
with other Devon authorities to make
sure that we're in accordance with them
but it's a local policy that we
recommend for you to adopt someone's
package
what comes to the question is first
speaker and then comes your door
thank you
um yeah I should really declare an
interest in this because I've probably
named most of the streets and benefits
for the last 35 years and I've always
tried to have a historical link
um whether it be landowners whether it
be a name of the fields that were there
before or whatever
um
I'm slightly surprised I've never heard
this
idea that you can only name streaks
after people who have passed on after 60
after 100 Years and we're almost running
out of mayor's names in Biddeford uh and
named them for that well I think we've
used that the last 40 years worth of
names nobody's ever queried it and we
even name one street after a living
person
um admittedly that was Clifford coats
the most highly decorated Armed Forces
member we've ever had in bit of it
um he was very touched by that I should
have
um the one thing that does slightly
worry me
um is the time scale this you're saying
that Parish Council has got 10 days
now some Parish councils don't meet the
months and months and even on benefit
town we have our planning committee
where we come up with the names that
only meets every three weeks and I think
10 days is an incredibly short because
these things can be very contentious uh
I get approached quite often about
people asking me with new names straight
after you know Granddad and all sort of
things and some of the names if the
people who live in Westwood home may
know
the very contentious issue over an
ex-german Northern UDC Mrs Hilda
which got very very contentious
um so I'd like that timely extended if
possible because I'm not quite sure how
you're going to get it within 10 days
um
as I say I should declare an interest
because at one time I'm pretty sure
there's going to be a bushby Boulevard
and perhaps even a Christy Concourse who
knows but
I would ask that we have that attended
and could I I will I'm not sure if he's
still here the naming officer we do have
a street naming officer
um I understand that if we wanted to use
the name of somebody who died within 60
years that it's up to the parishes
discretion
to do that
um and I would add that
uh
parishes if you get developers come
along to you and say oh we want this
name you can challenge them
and where developers have challenged bit
of a Town Council we've come back and we
said no we are having that and we've won
so you need to stick to your guns if
you're in the parish council to get the
name you want not what some developer
wants because most developers names are
very generic
and they're not very interesting at all
and they don't relate to the area you're
naming but uh I don't know if our street
naming off to come back and talk about
something I can I can address this
problem
so so like I mentioned earlier on this
is a locally approved policy and so the
time limit so they're uh sets at your
discretion so if you wanted to reduce
the 60 years to the lesser amount that
is possible
um we've been discussing this earlier on
and the reason the time limit was in
there is because uh people and issues
are contentious we live in a political
environment and so it was felt that and
and a sort of appropriate period of time
to have elapsed before something was
named after someone uh was there in
terms of weather names should have been
allocated to people who were still alive
or had passed away within 100 years that
shouldn't have happened and there have
been a number of cases obviously you've
cited some where things have slipped
through the net but there you go we can
uh that you know we're trying to tighten
processes up and make sure and again you
know these these are your rules and
regulations if you'd like to suggest a
change as such to you
um and I can't remember the last point
you were making what was the last point
about
the last bit marriage
the new touristy compassion was the
three main numbering Authority Town
Council recommends to you what should be
said uh set as the postal addresses and
then we apply the criteria of the policy
against that so again it's your rules
and regulations District Council as to
which part
um and developer recommendations come
forward and or measured so uh this this
is the document to set the rules uh that
applications are measured against
so it's the district pension Authority
not apparent pencil timeline again
that's that's up to you for uh parishes
if you wanted to stretch that out that
was suggested because it's more
operationally efficient than Bishop
pencil and our officers in processing
it's better for the customer if you'd
like to suggest slightly longer that's
entirely a good situation yeah yeah well
yes I would because a lot of the rural
parishes I think would be impossible to
do it in 10 days uh you know they might
be away on a holiday or whatever
um could I extend that to a month at
least and also could I lower the
post-mortem naming periods of 10 years
I'll put that as an amendment so check
and I just can I just check on the
street name in the number and obviously
there's no regulations that are uh there
is a regulation related timeline where
we have to main streets for these 30
days from notifications yeah that's the
reasons
I think I heard that sorry what do you
have 30 days from when we're at the
application was received to to apply the
address so that's why it's limited to 10
days to make it easier for us to process
so I guess so important extension to
that by a few days might help
um we're not going to be able to go to a
month because we wouldn't meet our own
deadlines that was pretty good can we
come back and suggest that as soon as
porridge is told that 30 days of the
month you contact the Parish Clerk on
that day and it runs from that day it's
a month
is that operationally possible
okay
in a few years
can you
just
as I say yeah it's on YouTube so
I'm sure there's a lot of um listeners
back there I want to hear every word
that said I think the points around
practicalities to swing boots up so I
think uh you know occasionally saying um
can you speak into the microphone sorry
I guess not saying that we want to be as
sufficient as possible so I think that
piece has been built up in the
conversations
okay
inevitably magnificent you know there's
looking at the Consulting the financials
as quickly as possible so it's not
massive or only something that we would
reasonably wants to commit to doing so
on the same thing yeah
it was fine
okay
you understand
yeah I was just going to suggest the uh
XP extended to 21 days which is three
weeks because Paris have been enough
time to draw a meeting on it but it also
allows to visit the district council a
week to
receive that response and the woman
necessary there's two there's an element
of the start of that processing at the
end
it might be a 10 day 10 day 10 day or it
might be a five day one two day five day
there are a lot of processes at either
end of the parish's consideration
well I can see where you're coming from
Sean and John I'm still at a bit of a
loss as to see what the urgency is
because you know when
we want to develop a planning to build
on a state of 500 houses or whatever you
know there's a very very long leading to
that
process wait before the housing is
actually completed and ruled for them
Etc why can't the
Street naming aspect of that be taken
far sooner and why is it sort of
condensed with that
there's just a point of the priority
soliciting one of the most vascular
points in the time and I think it's
Justified
um receiving information processing the
making foreign
suggest something around the logic of a
five-day period where it's reissue to
Parish councils another consideration
period at the end of the place and
submit the end so I think that was my
five days 20 days for five days fifteen
times ten days three months and some
some semantics in that I think is that
that logical processing the Turkish
district council at the beginning of
that 30-day period at the end of that
year
well I don't think I'm any further
forward but country brother
well yeah I can understand if it's from
the application coming in in its 30 days
that you've got to give the response by
but I thought when I read in 10 days if
it was 14 years because by the time the
time clock it gets that information
you've got to call them a special
meeting as a Clarence committee because
it's normally as a councilman Christie
said if it is ignore then the plans
committed is normally considering this
requests for enabled
but it's interesting to hear Council
Christie say about the historic names
that it's always good to try and attach
to these areas I would just ask that
where I used to live onto Valley Road
almost opposite Asda Martin Lodge live
there for 38 years
Harry ever became Adam's poor
because I I just do not know Heartland
Road Lodge was where I live use because
it's super fisherman Heartland Royal
Golf and the land all around there not
behind you where the forestry commission
was but all that numbers partner Road
Plantation
well if you could do that very briefly
he's an X-Men
I don't really I don't know
right so where are we with us is there
going to be an amendment to the time or
not
you're suggesting 10 days that's that's
on recommendations
[Music]
you've heard from sorry if you've heard
from all the councilors you know nobody
said that is efficient I think we're
dealing with a longer time okay I think
they propose uh maybe for that that was
20 days
rather than 10 days then
um our proposal Etc reports
um sorry I did suggest also reducing it
to uh 10 years
and
um there's probably a lot of people
have learned and after them in fancy
language you know modern era would maybe
we consider how that was approached oh
so long can I go within that roof by
time yes people are all judgments
Professor bright did you have your hand
up uh yeah
John the um naming both mortar
um part of the Town Council we're
looking for the day one street after
Elaine Queen Elizabeth which obviously
is less than 10 years so an exit more
difficult to do that and well at the
time
still it would be eligible under this
policy either can so in in terms of
naming things after um members of the
royal family uh there's a different set
of rules and we have to write and get
permission to do that anyway and I I as
I understand that could be done within
the period anyway with it
I have proposed 10 years I haven't had a
secondary but
um I would propose in 10 years and I
have to point out you could always
change street names it was done in
Biddeford uh in the 19th century we had
Cox Street for some reason the
victorians took offense at that and they
renamed it hard screen you can rename it
any like
how's the government I would like
[Music]
on the agenda but there we go that's a
lot yeah can you just confirm then is it
still in there that you can name a road
after someone that is living still
within the village that's not possible
and exactly though yeah as I said only
wrong chair I think they've been to
um some previous occurrences that have
slipped through the you know moving
forward checking and moving forward that
wouldn't happen moving forward when the
inductance policy that will not be the
case then yeah so what's being proposed
in amendments is that the uh the time of
it is is 10 years rather than 16 years
10 years post-mortem
and the consultation is 21 days
[Music]
um if you had
a local family
so under one that sticks in life okay is
Kingston Road over there
if
the person who remained after maybe
they died over 10 years ago then
what about all the other family members
that are kingdoms that are still alive
if you've got people still alive are you
therefore saying because
actually you can't name that road pink
and something because you've got other
people's everywhere
so chair I think I think we've just got
right to the Crux of why it's
complicated when you know things are
different when they remember all of a
sudden you get into well that that
that's the person who still currently
owns the site next door and you've got
all of this intention that goes with it
that time periods and laxation is
intended to wash some of this stuff
through so that it becomes less
contentious when that happens now
obviously you're going to get
occurrences like that that does happen I
can think of a number of other places
um where things are named after people
the very close Association of that piece
of land and that's probably because
history passion doesn't know about
Association yeah so I wouldn't you know
if Mr Pinkham used to own that piece of
land because why would I know that some
of that contact with local consultation
with the marriage pensions and you get
that feedback because they would also be
assessing against the criteria but in
the scheme of things I suppose what we
don't know how can it harm you if you're
putting best efforts to acquire the
policy and it happens that there's a
name Association that was not known you
could read
you know any associations
it is
sorry yeah but I think it's absolutely
right
um if if we're getting into real simple
complications I think it seems very
British to have a rule which bursting a
bit uh krakowanian actually and I would
actually go against Daniel rule because
I think it was simple okay then it would
get away from the discussions
but I think we should perhaps go back to
say a 50-year
recording if we're increasing the 21
days for Paris councils uh do we need to
look at extending the consultations for
applicants but obviously there's quite
often
conflict between the applicants and the
parishances and all these matters and if
you're saying you've got three weeks to
to consult applicants you know I think
we've been there and that has only got
five days it seems really about hard on
that side
it's it's a consideration check well I'm
quite happy with the 21 days now that to
me makes sense I haven't really got an
opinion one way or the other whether
it's 10 years 60 years or whatever
um hopefully I won't be around if uh
they're going to name anything after me
in the future but
um Dental
with those two amendments that it's 21
days and 10 years we're proposed by
cancer firstly seconded by Cancer girl
uh all in favor pre-show
thank you
against
on any extensions
2345 again thank you
okay well like I said let me expect that
one to take a lot of time item 11 to
answer questions submitted under
procedure rule A9 none have been
submitted
item 12 petitions we don't have any
petitions
uh and we have
four notices of motion one from and so
look Val who is really not here tonight
so that will be deferred to the time
when she does attend
uh the second one is from pastor craigie
yeah thank you I will be preparing those
information because obviously uh the uh
the leader and the person need to meet
uh with the exact real estate on the
phone further information from them
about how the allocation of funding will
take place uh appropriately I think that
while we do know what was the areas were
selected on as part of the leveling up
agenda that they need to improve the
quantity of people achieving
uh qualifications level three and above
the Improvement of longevity of Life uh
the Improvement of uh the earnings
average earnings in the area and the
gross value added of the economy there
is still not a clear system of how
they're going to evaluate those in terms
of how things are decided
um and so we've had to defer it on the
talk without anything after which time
you can have further clarities okay
thank you
okay the next one is uh Council weekly
yeah
um I moved the motion that Council
recognizes huge importance of the mobile
Library service across the whole of the
tourist District
we request Devon County Council we think
they're decision to close the service
automation
we also asked Kevin County Council to
explore future opportunities at the
mobile online service which is an
advanced lies influences
you know KDC during public support
including celebrities
mobile Library service in place
focus on the foundation of education and
Target is one of the most deprived
districts in the county so the whole
lesson communities
properties deprivation isolation
and
loneliness we should be increasing
access to both not remove them
and we also propose that we haven't
recorded both regarding this motion
thank you
yeah
we did write to Dunham County Council I
believe a couple of a couple of meetings
back on this subject so I'm always
suggesting that we write a further
letter to Devon County council with our
with our objections yes yes
okay um recorded books record for so
yeah again I'm quite happy for electric
go forward because the internal Spirit
movement was called for an investigation
into it so we could support that rather
than just sending them with them now
there's a there is a process going on at
the Devon County so we can support that
process
so in order for a recorded vote to take
nice we need at least five members to
actually support that
bury them you need you need the numbers
okay so um it's been proposed by Council
we we seconded by country James
show of hands and support please
counselor Andrews
Pastor Andrews
are you in support
yes it's a recorded vote so you have to
shut your mouth
foreign
[Music]
counselor Hicks okay
Governor Olson
thanks for the hinge or Pastor James
Paul Council Jones or Council 11.
Council look again abstain sorry I'm
staying yeah
Thomas or Council weekly or Council of
Whitaker insane
[Music]
thank you
okay the next one is uh Patrick honkin
um foreign
[Music]
when such land is available and
considered appropriate this Council will
actively support local communities and
bring forward their own local housing
schemes
so I put something similar for this for
the last Council and there seemed to be
a lot of support for it but I should
bring it back for those motion that's
what I've done and there's a housing
crisis in torrent and as a local
Authority we rarely meet the 30
affordable housing Target for Housing
Development experience we don't own
enough simple lands but deliver our own
housing and therefore hopefully it would
be the best for our communities that we
as a council enable parishes to create
their own in the form of Community
Management
as part of our housing links they enable
the communities to have an input and a
say in how things are done because we
need not just affordable hands we need
social housing development and so I
think it's very important that this goes
ahead
now James
yeah
not quite clear why you know the remote
first to Temporary house in my
understanding was but we're going to be
looking at sites for tampering and urban
housing on unemploitable and social
basis having said that my support
of encouraging land trusts right we
haven't even thought about having a
five-minute debate on this but I mean
unless it's urgent casual that's are you
going to add something
yeah um unfortunately support the motion
but I didn't want to do that the poor
Council we have is identifying the
landowners and I would suggest the first
step that we should do is the right to
individual Parish penalties and our
certainly circulate to all their members
because they will be more aware of what
land is available
so I think an initial letter should go
out from tolerance for the requests
so they can identify within their own
parishes good idea
in my war that we've got a community
dancer that set up in gravity and it was
no means before the
um committee to actually keep that
running and overcome major obstacles
that came to the British and throughout
the build
um Rachel Webb Jones University at the
time and she enabled
um or helped enable a lot of fulfilled
and since that had been built out
um
and various other very small villages
have wanted to develop their affordable
housing but unfortunately it's very very
small the contribution was very very
small now we don't have as far as I'm
aware yet but with the face of the
Rachel Webber he did and she left so
there is actually what we may have land
available there is no support to be in
college
furthermore if you want to go through
all these Community managers want to go
um in collaboration with Westwood or
Wessex
um
there are other enabling
that help
Ed
in small properties of Norway
so actually to get anyone on board if
you set up your community of address big
tick well done they're more
there is no other party to help you
build out or take on that property for a
couple of properties at the moment and
there certainly isn't any
um line within storage by which our
communities will use that to communicate
through and then enable the build that
process so there's a whole bigger
picture in the show and I do I support
emotion but it's more than just bringing
the land forward there's a whole raft of
obstacles in the way that really you
know are inhibiting
it needs to be
um really thought out and well let me
just bring in the chief executive
thanks chair
um just a response councilor darty is
absolutely right that post uh is
currently vacant and it's supposed to be
seeking to recruit to
um currently
um so it is a post in the establishment
that will be recruited to to do this
type of work
trying to improve that goal
so yeah I think I think you you're right
it was a difficult role to recruit to
and the last time we we appointed
someone they came in a different cell
um this is clearly enabling workers
we're talking about here and I guess all
we can do is go to the market and see
who's out there
um I chased uh Helen this week now she's
back off I believe because we need those
job description we want to try and tweak
it from last time because I don't think
we've quite had the emphasis right last
time
um and we hope to be out with an advert
as soon as possible the money for the
purchases in the budget which is a job
so I can find someone if we don't find
someone I think you know that there is
an urgency Associated we're gonna have
to have a rethink on our strategy about
how we do this enabling working because
it isn't just a cot piece of work it's a
whole wider piece of enabling that needs
to be done
getting that I'm sorry yeah yeah could I
just come in very briefly I am a
director of the CLT the quite a
successful one but there is an enormous
amount of background work that needs to
be done there is two elements of the
encouragement and one is that we are
advertising for a post and we're looking
for the type of person that will be able
to help with that the second one is I
sit on the Devon posting task force and
there is quite a movement within Devon
County
um and the LGA to move towards more
support for Community Land across and
part of their thing is to try and bring
more funding in specifically for the
last three years the clts have been upon
a 60 million and none of that's
materialized at all
um so there is a lot of thought and all
I would suggest with this is that we
accept the principle we can there's a
reason we don't put it out to Parish
councils a word of warning that is an
awful lot of work involved and very
short of money at this moment in time so
I'm quite happy to support
okay it's been proposed by Council
Colorado
with those um alterations that country
lock suggested that uh always right to
parachuters is that right yeah yeah okay
all those in favor please show
me again
foreign